Sao ngày hai người tháng 6 đã bây giờ của trong hai người sau,
tại cố gộn bụng biệt vệ phía phần sát lần sân.
Tình thinh hoa sẽ ra vụ tên an sát thông giữ xe ông Tô Đầu Kéo Sau ông Lồ Đi S,
sinh nămu nghìn trí chân bệ bếm ốt, chú tại sát xấu vòng,
tình thinh hoa, yêu khiến với xe đạp xấu bản lựa tên được,
sinh nămu nghìn trí chân bệ bế tham, chú tại sát thảo lập tình thinh hoa,
đều khiến đang xí chuyển của chiều, khẩu qua, bản lựa tử bong tại chỗ,
hịt bụt tên an đặc đường đều chào dậy quyết thử quy định.
Qua bụt biệt chinh, phòng cạnh sát xấu thông công an tình thinh hoa,
khuyến cáo người dân khi tham sát xảo thông.
Lối với xe mụt, xe đánh mấy, xe đạp,
phải chủ í quân sát, giảm tốc độ, giữ khoảng kế an toàn khi xí chuyển gần xe tại lần,
đặc biệt tại quốc gặp ná ba, ná bố khi xe tại đang xế,
không dừng lâu khoảng trên bởi mụ khi xe tại dừng đen đó.
Lối với xe tại, phải chủ í quân sát, giảm tốc độ khi bởi mụt ngá ba,
ná bốn, nhất là khi xe nên lắp thêm camera xúc quán và gử vụ.